on verra bientôt plus les fameux tigres
dans la salle aux trésors de fort boyard
sur france 2 hier alexia laroche joubert
la productrice de l'émission a annoncé
que les deux tigres tosca et cachemire
ne seront pas remplacés après leur
retraite une mesure qui intervient au
moment où la ministre de la transition
écologique barbara comment elle a décidé
d'interdire progressivement les animaux
sauvages dans les cirques itinérants une
première pour une émission nous allons
nous poser la question êtes vous pour ou
contre les animaux à la télé christophe
dechavanne moi je vois lâché j'ai des
fans quand il était avec des émissions
avec des animaux à l'époque il n'en a
fait plein aussi après on sait on ce
même inspiré lui dans tpm p regardez le
sujet christophe nous rejoint et on va
en parler tous ensemble et ça c'est vrai
que ça divise énormément ça réagit déjà
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est parti bientôt
lorsque vous regarderez fort boyard
vous ne verrez plus ça car c'est
officiel depuis hier la production de
l'émission a décidé de ne plus avoir de
tigres dans son programme
[Musique]
des tigres qui pourtant à l'image du
père fouras font la marque de l'émission
[Musique]
au point que chaque année depuis 26 ans
le programme mobilise des moyens énormes
pour acheminer les félins à l'intérieur
du fort
une demi heure de traversée pour les
tigres enfermés dans leur cage
une grue pour les déposer dans le fort
avant deux mois de tournage intensif aux
missions qui font hurler le journaliste
activiste hugot clément au micro
d'europe 1 hier matin j'espère que la
production de fort boyard va décider
d'arrêter les tigres parce que ça
n'apporte plus rien aujourd'hui
dans cette émission et je trouve ça
anachronique de continuer à utiliser ces
animaux sauvages dans un but de
divertissement pourrait même son cloche
pour le vidéaste rémi gaillard
je refuse d'y défendre une association
tant que la production utilisera des
animaux pour faire le show les décision
inédite car depuis quarante ans les
animaux font les belles heures de la
télé dans un registre bonne enfant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et parfois plus discutable
il veut seulement
sur cette vache et la pauvre sinon
andres 2
alors pour ou contre les animaux à la
télé avec lui qui nous a fait passer des
moments exceptionnels avec des animaux
christophe dechavanne est avec lui
[Applaudissements]
merci m
tu es là tu as fait tu te prends mais je
me suis qui je veux je me suis fait
attaquer par dix mecs je leur ai mis
leurs menaces mais je me suis déchiré
non tu les laisses parce qu'après je
peux pas marrer c'est une blague et je
les donne après comme ça moi je suis le
gars est inquiète mais sinon je te
ramène commencé à montrer que je suis
très content de te voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on dirait que vous êtes comme des oufs
la première fois que je suis très
content d'être là parce que si vous
voyez faire une émission on parle des
animaux
ouais où je suis pas là ces mêmes partis
et j'adore ces deux petits gars histoire
est très joli mais je crois que j'ai
entendu ici dire bois de chavannes façon
sérieuse been tu l'as déjà je me
souviens qu'il y avait qui avait une
émission où ça parler de toi on dit et
on n'a pas de dicter à ce que vous
parlez anglais en tout cas on ne se
souvient pas du tout d'avoir dit ça
franchement je le rassure souviens qu'il
y avait un petit débat sur ça et on
disait un porte voix des examens des
programmes non non non non franchement
écrits ont pu se tuer il a raison et la
très bonne mémoire si si on avait déjà
fait parler d'eux
merci chris thomas la dette la série
vous voulez parler les animaux les
animaux à la télé et ça repart des
extraits dans un instant voilà vraiment
on s'est régalé avec toi dans les
animaux la télé aujourd'hui franchement
il ya plein de gens devant moi qui me
disent aussi les producteurs et tous
deux chavanne ça nous manque de savane
avec les animaux et c est ce que toi tu
serais capable de le refaire aujourd'hui
ou plus du tout a changé d'avis tu
pourrais plus faire ce que tu viendras
du pas d'une vie mais ça c'est une chose
et l'autre par la réglementation et l je
suis soufflé pardon mais là aussi je ne
sais pas qui avait quatre bornes entre
la est-ce que tu veux que ça j'arrête
cadavre est un titre croulants nation
mais c'est comme ça fait six semaines
que je bouge plus je suis gros comme une
vache et non tu sais comment va la
présenter un extrait c'est continuer en
deux mois par deux mois manik plus que
vous m'avez posé de questions je juge je
réponds oui j'ai changé d'avis donc je
vous en parlerai j'ai évolué comme la
société comme le public comme tout le
monde on a fait des trucs absolument
formidable on a fait des trucs
probablement que je ne serai plus du
tout mais je ne regrette rien en tout
cas voilà alors je passe rien a toujours
veillé à ce que ça se passe très très
très proprement très on va on va voir
des images et c'est vrai que voilà donc
ousseynou moi j'étais but
voilà c'était fou moi je rentrais pour
sa pluie de voix là où je voulais voir
absolument et était tout petit bah ouais
mais mais mais mais mais je me régalais
il ya une image à creusot coucou c'est
nous c'est quand vous avez reçu un ours
sur le plateau non rappelle christophe
ballot ouais c'est que j'avais un peu
perdu la mémoire du jeu avec l'ours et
des chamallows rappel de sa salle et il
faut bien qu'il y en a profité pour mon
lapin regardes tu fermes les yeux et
hummer la bouche tu l'as sortir dans la
première spéciale pour elle que loïc
devaux
[Applaudissements]
tata nano avec gagnent elles généraient
tard et christophe ça ça aujourd'hui
alors ça a beaucoup évolué je voudrais
vous à voir ceux qui sont pour les
animaux à la télévision isabelle moign
aux 7 po et encore oui moi je suis et
pourquoi pas mais que j'ai bossé dans le
domaine animalier il avoue travailler
dans un zoo à l'époque oui sur le je
suis contre évidemment qu'on amène des
ours sur le plateau mais on peut pas
dire qu'il faut interdire tous les
animaux sur un plateau notamment les
animaux familiers de vente ce qui est
des animaux qui aiment ça et quand ils
sont avec leur propriétaire en
respectant les consignes évidemment de
nom de nombreux noms lumière trônait ça
peut être extrêmement pédagogique pour
des enfants qui bientôt nous n'aurons
plus à la télé on n'a pas précision par
l'équipe des noirs les des animaux
effectivement la semaine dernière y
avait des chiens des chats et même une
petite chèvre sur un plateau et
honnêtement les enfants étaient fascinés
les avait il y avait une vraie
connaissance et l'assedic là dessus
hamad a raison les animaux plus que sur
des images attendues dans la nature tout
disait quand même un peu trop mais dans
un zoo et dire autant de conneries c'est
pas permis
on respecte ma belle la l2 donc voilà je
trouve que dire unilatéralement il faut
il faut pas des animaux qui sont
totalement imprégné qui ont l'habitude
de faire ça si vous leur enlevez cette
habitude de jour au lendemain ils sont
paumés les animaux sont tous les jours
la même chose ils mangent tous les jours
la même chose alors utile et ceux qui
disent il faut pas d'animaux ne les
connaissent par 6 alors qu il ya une
image qu'on voulait revoir parce que les
tigres on les reverra bientôt plus dans
fort boyard ce que vous rappelez de
baptiste giabiconi fatfat si c'est bien
sûr vrai flip
il a eu
le montant des dégâts atteint les
puzzles sont dégonflés haut niveau s'il
vous plaît si opérable c'est bon vous
rigolez tout mais j'ai peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non mais maintenant elle a raison c'est
à dire que les animaux qui sont élevées
depuis des années par des gens qui
s'occupent bien de d'abord son
inlassable parce qu'il mourrait donc que
maintenant ça ne continue pas c'est un
vrai débat mais que ceux qui sont là
doivent finir évidemment leur vie comme
ils y ont commencé ils sont à peu près
tous nés en captivité
enfin je veux dire on peut pas relâcher
des animaux sauvages comme ça nous on
fait une émission ici sur celui
magnifique qui s'appelle la tanière et
qui est le premier refuge de france à
recevoir et que les animaux de cirque et
des animaux sauvages et tout ça on fait
aussi animaux adoptés et nos animaux
adoptés j'suis fan juste non parce que
comme je suis dans évidemment on a fait
des choses qu'aujourd'hui on
n'accepterait pas mais plus les gens le
public n'acceptera pas et que moi même
peut-être bon ça à part un petit flirt
ça va mais mais mais par exemple la spa
en 2019 a fait sa plus belle année
d'adoption grâce à l'émission qu'on fait
sur ces huit dont et qui s'appelle
animaux à de mauvaises pistes
donc on peut participer à au bien-être
des animaux bien sûr c'est vrai que
plateau n'est pas forcément le vrai
biotope où les animaux doit se trouver
voilà il ya un autre écrit joué à voir
donc poussé nous 193e un orang outan sur
le plateau et entre veut c'est très
chaud christophe mais je crois que j'ai
la cote donc pongo pygmaeus ce qui veut
dire en indonésien en des bois oui
on ne connaît pas du tout à l'heure je
suis mal
il a juste mon cou dans sa main et
puissant comme un camion non c'est sa
supply chain
ben oui comme ready fois plus puissant à
wiesen puissante règle étant
certainement mais en fait il est pas il
n'est pas il n'est pas conscient de sa
force mais c'est vrai que quand on voit
ça moi tu vois là où je suis je suis
attendri par ce que je vois là un
christophe cynisme
voilà c'est une séquence magnifique vous
êtes contre valérie depuis le plus
longtemps
très honnêtement ma ma réflexion a
évolué et moi ça me choquerait pas à
l'époque mais j'avoue que la société a
évolué donc j'ai évolué avec la société
et je me suis effectivement rendu compte
que ce n'était pas leur place et à
l'époque moi je trouvais ça génial je
trouve ça sympathique et effectivement
je trouvais que c'était des séquences
agréable à regarder et on voyait bien
que les propriétaires étaient pas mal
traitant avec leurs animaux surtout
qu'ils avaient une vie commune depuis 30
ans sauf que maintenant évidemment tout
ça a changé et que moi je préfère
aujourd'hui voir les animaux non pas sur
ce par exemple sur ce plateau vous irez
vous en aviez arrêté
vous avez arrêté et je préfère les voir
dans des émissions dans les refuges dans
les zoos dans des endroits où ou dans
des documentaires animaliers mais pas
sur un plateau avec un public avec des
néons avec des applaudi et c'est alors
tâche albaz oui qu'est le plus jeune
l'émission huilée pour un même si
j'adore les animaux je donnerais ma vie
pour les animaux il ya deux choses la
première chose c'est une info j'ai
enquêté
j'ai appelé quelqu'un qui travaille dans
la production la ferme célébrités une
émission qui a brillamment présenté
christophe dechavanne et dans cette
émission là les animaux étaient très
très bien traité il ya ce qu'on appelle
avait pensé à ça c'est à dire deux
heures par jour
eh bien les on arrête de tourner et à ce
moment là il y avait des vétérinaires et
des fermiers qui s'occupait de tous les
animaux première chose et la deuxième
chose c'est si on se met à interdire les
animaux pourquoi ils viennent sur les
plateaux télé c'est pour divertir le
public se sont attendez attendez donc à
ce moment là on va interdire les eaux
jean michel qui quitte sa famille on va
interdire on interdire le cerveau avec
les cultures il faut se balader dans les
couloirs où il ya des vaches on va
interdire les courses hippiques
on va interdire
bientôt les chiens et les chats dans les
appartements passé ils sont pas assez
est-ce qu'il en a perdu tout moi c'est
ridicule c'est à dire que franchement je
ne savais plus si je n'écris pas des
animaux et des enfants pardon mais je
pense que des enfants qui n'ont pas
l'occasion mois puisqu'il parle de ferme
célébrités j'avais des petits stagiaires
qui étaient là qui a vu son âge qui
avait jamais vu de poules de leur vie
qu'ils étaient citadins ou qui étaient
nés dans des banlieues qu'il n'ait
travaillé chez endemol qui avait jamais
touché un animal qu'elle n'avait jamais
vu je pense que les eaux à condition
évidemment que les choses se passent
bien
pédagogiquement des mômes qui n'ont pas
l'occasion d'aller je ne sais pas en
afrique au kenya voir là pour l'instant
c'est marrant mais allez voir des
animaux debout sur pattes dans leur
milieu éducative mans et p2
pédagogiquement c'est c'est bien je
pense que ça n'est pas un mal de voisine
mot évidemment il faut que ces animaux
soient totalement bien traitée et ne pas
les exclure du milieu sauvage pour les
mettre dans un milieu fermé
ça ce serait quand on parle des orangs
outans là vous avez c'est un excellent
exemple parce que laurent où tu en es tu
meurs plus en ce moment de la
déforestation est dans la nature où il
ya plus d'habitants
vous avez un animal qui aime le contact
avec toi prendre jusqu'à après il y aura
je trouvais moi ça me rend complètement
dingue en fait je suis pas spécialement
la défenseuse de la cause animale
on a tous été est où ici autour de la
table beaucoup plus sensibilisés à la
cause animale
donc forcément on est sensibilisé on n'a
pas envie de les voir sur des plateaux
tout à l'heure il avait lui disais ils
sont d'accord mais je comprends pas tu
leur demandes avant de rentrer sur le
plateau mais attendez moi je la là
franchement c'est pas possible je ne
peux pas entendre vos arguments mais
c'est n'importe quoi
les animaux n'ont plus rien à faire sur
des bateaux on le sait y lobbysme avril
cité à temps je termine il ya une
opacité derrière on ne sait pas s'ils
sont bien traités on peut pas le
garantir
en attendant pendant 15 ans j'ai eu un
petit chat qui s'appelait avec je vous
jure je vous jure jo jury des litres il
va bien traités c'est l'autre et oui la
mairie souhaitait c'était son
coanimateur je disais toujours voilà
d'ailleurs et qu'on apprenait christine
ans avec le chien alors on va voir un
extrait vous avez fait très fort un jour
christophe en montant tout simplement
sur un éléphant sur votre plateau c'est
vrai que c'est vous qui avez donné
l'idée à tout le monde après de mettre
des animaux sur le plat c'est pas
forcément une bonne idée un recul bien
sûr mais christophe olive oil et ne le
ferai plus mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
c'était une séquence et on va pas se
mentir on attendait on attendait les
animaux sur christophe parce que qu'est
vous et patrice carmouze avec les
animaux on savait que ça allait être
exceptionnel et aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que c'est un truc qu'on pourrait plus
faire mais en terme de divertissement
si aujourd'hui on peut on le ferait plus
mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque voilà on
avait l'impression que le poids on avait
des crocodiles qui était à deux mètres
regardez là vous êtes sur un éléphant
c'est sur un plateau signes laissent
trop grave
et c'est là c'est sûr que va descendre
maintenant qu'est ce qu'il fait là
monsieur c'est vous parler d'eux en
train de me bt avec sa peine
[Applaudissements]
question jeudi c'est quelqu'un qui a un
amour pour les animaux d'ailleurs voilà
il produit deux animaux chez nous sur
ces vite qui font énormément pour la spa
voilà je voulais animaux adoptés
c'est l'émission qui a fait vraiment
avancer les choses quand vous le faisait
à l'époque c'est parce que vous aimiez
les animaux si je croyais je les aime
toujours
ouais je les aime toujours mais c'est
vrai qu'en regardant ces images j'ai
évolué comme d'identité pardon et gg je
ne leur ferai plus ouais ouais
maintenant ces animaux sont nés en
captivité ils ont grandi il faut juste
pas oublié un truc parce qu'on parle
beaucoup des animaux de cirque et je
vous garantis que les familles d'animaux
qui a faim les familles de cire qui
circulent d'animaux il les aime
1-0 fondement ça c'est sûr oui je le
sais on les connaît mais sur ce qu'il
disait évidemment on l'ucad et il ya des
moutons noirs partout mais il les aime
profondément vraiment vraiment origine
on peut plus défendre le fait que des
animaux soient la télé aujourd'hui parce
qu'à l'époque de christophe on ne savait
pas aujourd'hui on sait aussi que les
tic sont transportés maltraités il ya
même des six ans mais on sait et les
émincer énervé c'est purement et
simplement de la maltraitance vernement
km mais sacha vous êtes fait berlue
réparé quelqu'un qui vous a dit que 2e
et blu-ray série le petit ya des gros
soupçon il ya des gros soupçon que les
animaux je parle pas forcément de fort
boyard soit drogué qu'on leur donne des
médicaments qu on les conditionne pour
accepter donc c'est inacceptable c'est
tout simplement de la maltraitance qui
n'a plus lieu d'être aujourd'hui mais
sincèrement les gars vous parler de
sentiments on en a strictement mais rien
à faire des sentiments qu'on les
dresseurs envers leurs animaux mais
sincèrement mais qu'est ce qu'on en a à
faire l'animal à partir du moment où il
est sur un plateau où il est dans un
cirque où les dents un machin le les
sentiments que son dresseur il en a rien
à faire tout ce qui s'est lui même si
qu'il est malheureux et qu'il n'a pas
être un plateau c'est tout mais comment
vous le savez le mets toi comment tu le
jean michel et nadine l'énormité il ne
faut pas les laisser se reproduire
passager pincé terminé marine ou saverne
après ensuite il faut juste voir deux
choses c'est que on parle des animaux
domestiques ou des animaux non mais pas
tous les débats si c'est tous les
animaux la cause est noble ne faut pas
partir dans les extrêmes je suis je ne
suis pas d'accord avec le fait que
bernard depuis ce plus ramené son chien
en plateau ça je trouve ça vraiment mais
d'une stupidité monstre parce qu
appartement nous c'est un animal
domestique il a dit être à l'intérieur
et qu'il a avec son maître pourquoi pas
après que ce soit les animaux sauvages
oui là c'est autre chose giambi java
faut dire que tu aimes les animaux il
est réjoui recueillait des titres qui
sont en fort boyard jeu murray excuse
moi ils sont nos sens nos milieux de la
pierre au milieu du gué des embruns
marins extra qui est pas du tout leurs
2020 turenne milieu même s'ils ont connu
que ça et alors toi tu es du chemin on
tourne maintenant je dis on va jusqu'à
la fin de ta vie wade sont toutes a
connu que ça mais ça ne vole en éclats
tentures fait faire des choses comme
dans un cirque qui leur fait faire la
révérence marché soit un ballon ils ont
su dès des dizaines de dominer de coûts
d'électricité ou de pic pour l'apprendre
à faire ça tu verras jamais fait non
c'est pareil d'un éléphant cie qui lit
un livre et boit un café
ce qui évidemment est totalement
inadmissible et un animal dans un zoo
fait parce qu'ils sourient des ménages
cdma préservation des espèces les
espèces les espèces n'ont pas attendu
depuis l'ère des mammouths chinois sans
du lycée les mammouths ont attendu et
comme on reconnaisse comme les poires
date ça c'est vous faire l'argent pour
qui les gens n'avaient pas besoin de
réserver 2 on n'aime pas leurs animaux
isabelle isabelle venir ça serait tous
morts parce qu'ils ont du mal à
percevoir et ben il serait mort et alors
il n'y a pas d'autre
on aurait pu alors on se calme on
soutient jean lautrey l'image que c'est
vrai que j'ai des choses qu'on verra
plus et des choses qui nous on suit pas
et si on l'a vu passer jacques bouriez
jacques bouriez qui était dans 42 gras
long qui arrive avec un gros chien on
laisse regarder ça c'est des images
qu'on verra plus il sert et que c'est
des images qui nous ont fait mourir de
rire à regarder bon moi je suis avec
luca c'est la chaîne de madame rosmorduc
et moi je savais que ya le co oui la
fermeture les la famille le visage bon
allez c'est fini maintenant gacko crois
que ça fait plaisir à papa sa yaris est
ce qu'on peut faire c'est à rejoindre
oui qu'est-ce qu'on va qui on marche moi
alors je vais en profiter je vais en
profiter pour vous regardez les tenants
et les aboutissants de la rubrique pas
si vous avez peur des animaux c'est mal
parti jacquin d'un an mais ses courbes
énervé il y en a pour deux mois après
noël tranquille avec un chameau tisser
ou regardent pas les femmes s en avant
aulas alors au fond va peut-être le
faire asseoir
[Applaudissements]
gauche bonus ou la gauche à mascouche
oh là là mais moins qu'attendu
vous devez tout fait pour mais qu'est ce
que c'est de se séparer au méthane ya
plus de dix ans alors il ya ceux qui
sont les sardes ya plus nuancée où tous
les ans tout l'hôtel et même vous marrez
dont les images et c'est christophe il
adore les animaux il ya des gens
formidables et la relation homme et
animal existe alors été de dire que ça
qu'elle n'existe pas alors dans certains
cas vente au fait du mal d'animaux
évidemment on est tous d'accord vous
c'était un certain non débat quel est le
problème
un chien qui va sur un plateau et que
son maître cours et le problème il n'y a
pas de problème ce qu'il a envie de
venir sur les tuer mais ces débits
tintin
vous êtes donc on m'a traitée et
savoir-être et et on s'arrange il ya des
jours où il veut pas venir il ya quand
même effectivement on vous reparle alors
on fait un amalgame figuriez il ya des
gens qui sont épouvantables cela il faut
dit il ceux qui vivent les condamnés et
les punir il ya plein de gens d'abord il
est ou qui vivent de ça excuse
et surtout ça fait parfois du bien aux
animaux il faut pas faire un amalgame
gigantesque vous êtes 8v blanc ou noir
plus tard me fait un peu de temps en
temps
[Applaudissements]
j'ai retrouvé le castaldi vraiment non
mais là tu le fais cette caste à la
castagne bernard montiel vous avez fait
des émissions sur le fait une amie de
choses sur les animaux oui toujours
actuellement mais moi par exemple
j'avais mon labrador sur la vita vous
sur toutes les émissions en direct
il était heureux d'être avec moi je suis
[Musique]
évidemment d'heure ils étaient heureux
qu'avec moi ta gueule et je peux parler
donc je vous explique je présente depuis
quelques années une émission sur les
animaux aussi sur la chaîne animaux
paris veut faire un peu de promo le
groupe média one non c'est pas ça mais
jusqu'à présent les nouveaux animaux de
compagnie les comptes présentés dans
chaque émission on l'a arrêté cette
année à la nouvelle saison il y en aura
pas parce que nous aussi on a réfléchi
nous aussi on a évolué et ont trouvé ça
assez choquant effectivement et même les
invités qui venait à chaque fois nous
faisait la roma donc du coup on a arrêté
et il avait raison voilà donc je suis
content sont présentes mais c'est une
télé d'un autre temps on a tous rigolé
on a tous sourient en regardant ces
images mais maintenant en 2010 on a
d'autres candidats sont légion et vous
n'aimez pas ce que j'ai fait il ya une
opacité et bien on tente dans ces cas là
je mets ma cassette et je regarde les
dvd des émissions christophe j'ai pas
besoin d'euro alors des excuses moi il
ya aussi des dvd
[Rires]
alors
en fait ce débat il est parti de la
disparition des tic dans fort boyard on
va vous montrer une autre image des
tigres c'était vous rappelez de sophie
forte être comédienne sur qui a eu un
petit problème avec les tigres
regardez
[Musique]
ap
m
lee
[Applaudissements]
plus il y en a un qui est parti en
retraite le remplace pas les maisons
qu'il les supplie monde progressivement
créé partir en retraite ils ont trois et
neuf ans il est pollué ou encore de
souffrir pendant pas mal de temps on n'a
pas trop compris moi c'est l'essentiel
honda comparution plan de la tuerie je
resterai d'autrefois boyard six
applications encore les serpents ah bah
non il ya toujours en tout cas dans
boyard long il ya toujours plein de
bébêtes il ya toujours des scorpions et
tout ça on peut imaginer les circoncis
mais qu'est ce qu'on voulait supprimer
oui il est question de supprimer donc là
ça s'est terminé avec jari regarder
ouverture de la troisième peut trouver
tous les midis enfants sonatrach jarry
s'il vous plaît je ne peux pas je dois
pop sont surtout présents des seuils
attendait les pirates raft mort arriver
à les monter jarry pierre voilà c'est le
premier pied qui compte
quel est le signe de l'année 2015 en
astrologie chinoise
la chèvre bien le serbe a fait la
distinction avec les animaux domestiques
c'est à dire nos chiens de chats qu'on
amène avec nous qu'ils sont qui sont nos
compagnons tous les jours et puis les
nac ou encore des animaux des félins et
autres ça n'a rien à voir
ça n'a rien à voir on peut amener son
chien sur un plateau de télévision mais
en revanche effectivement d'aider des
animaux de qui sont pas domestiques
n'ont pas lieu d'être
mais alors on va voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs après jour une dernière
image a beau montrer
il va pour à 46% contre à 54,3 excellent
est beaucoup pour les pour les gens
parce que christophe je pense que c'est
en fait je pense que pourquoi autant de
pour c'est que c'est tellement des bons
souvenirs pour les téléspectateurs que
ils disent ouais ça nous énerve jeu
il faut comprendre l'évolution de la
société il faut se dire que papa
d'amalgamé évidemment de deux façons en
toute chose
mais dès les animaux a priori leur
biotope c'est pas un plateau télé voilà
donc on a eu une ou à l'époque on avait
du mal à faire rentrer une chèvre jouer
une anecdote qui va jouer je me faire de
vous le faire des français n'ont alors
rien sinon je ne peux pas alors mais si
c'est parce qu'il y avait michel klein
qui était le pont des vétérinaires a été
notre note notre notre garant que tout
se passait bien
et un jour il y avait une chèvre qui
voulait pas rentrer sur le plateau et il
l'a fait petite fille que pour la
détendre et puis bon la chèvre n'est
jamais arrivé à la fin d'émission
je suis allé voir j'ai dit mais là
chèvres allez oust et tout le monde est
un petit peu gêné et benjamin petit peu
la langue qui pendouillait et je suis
allé voir en fait il avait un peu chargé
la mule le dr klein oui les chefs tout
le monde en mangeant va se calmer sur
les chèvres
enfin cela dit elle s'est remise mais
elle était comme hors tabac ce que j'ai
dit mais qu'est ce qu'on fait elle avait
la langue qui permet une presque le
massage cardiaque et michel km à 10 200
francs christophe je voudrais dire et
qui se trouvait alors vécu
non mais c'est voilà ça aussi ça c'est
un truc je suis sûr que christophe
d'ailleurs ici dit voilà c'est compliqué
vous avez beaucoup de plainte à l'époque
parce que nous non on a on a on a fait
venir des animaux un moment dans
l'émission on sait fille fracassement
parce que c'était pas la même époque que
les diamants et trouver leur compte
qu'on veut qu'on s'amuse et on leur
faisait pas de mal que c'était rigolo
que bon c'est sûr que quand on met
frédéric mitterrand sur une autruche
c'est pas cool pour l'autre juge même et
en même temps voilà c'était c'était une
autre société on voit c'était un autre
monde une autre vision et ma foi voilà
on tout le monde grandit on a un regard
différent heureusement et je comprends
tout à fait et je suis comme les gens
qui ne désirent plus à voir cyril ces
bateaux mais hornu évidemment un chien à
poisson rouge ou hamster n'avait pas la
même limonade que l'hélium
alors il ya un truc qui assiste les
extraits cultes avec un animal c'est
avec marie ange nardi
elle s'était fait attaquer par un lion
ça ça a été un excès qu'elle fait peur
et lettres des blessés bonjour sans
qu'ils aient quitté son petit lion ben
oui ça lui va bien quantitié quel âge il
a 16 mois voilà voilà voilà [ __ ] donc
titre qu'est ce n'est pas quoi faire
mais oui faut pas qu'elles viennent mais
oui bon alors titi donc à 16 mois il a
donc sauté sûr sûr sûr mariage
et ça ça se passe pas très bien là il a
les griffes et christophe tu me parlais
d'une image
c'est un des moments qui vous a fait le
plus flipper pendant les séquences avec
des animaux sont 2007 dans l'émission
bête de scène ce soir là on est passé à
deux doigts du g du drame avec un tigre
a de a1 à a2 ongles ouais ouais vraiment
sa causerie de fou regarde et on a
l'image sa nature à mon meilleur ami et
qu'on s'occupe de toute ma famille sélam
hamad et ta femme
ok c'est là tout va bien
toi mr tout va bien tout va bien
depuis il était gentil lapin sorti les
griffes sinon oui quoi peut-être pas là
pour vous raconter ça arrive on voit
manu payet qui est qui et qui
moi aussi j'ai fait de ma culotte